why are men less forgiving about a woman
cheating on them than a woman
I felt that because men and women
cheating is different why couldn't he
really asking them kind of questions
yeah I'm sorry do you know why and I've
never cheated by the way let's put that
on the record but I'm just saying like I
just see a lot of men that are way more
heartbroken and way more like able to
throw away a whole relationship of a
woman instead of looking and thinking
maybe I was less emotionally available
for her maybe I wasn't mentally
stimulating her what was I doing where's
the accountability
when a woman cheats but when a man
cheats women must take accountability
for some part in in that situation okay
men and women are different so so men
can when a man cheats it doesn't mean
that he doesn't love you he he just has
like again guys see sex as a handshake
that's how they see it women we release
a chemical during sex when we orgasm ASM
that mate that attaches us to that guy
that's why girls always go back to the
best sex of their life no matter like it
doesn't matter what the hell he did
she's coming back if that was the best
sex of her life right
but you know what I'm talking about
right right so this is what I'm saying
men and women cheating is different
because to man it's nothing to women
it's we we release a hormone they don't
so if a woman cheats she doesn't love
you if a man cheats he still can I'm not
saying to accept cheating but I'm just
saying it's different I just wondered
I've always wondered that question so
yeah it's it's disgusting also you know
also you're always going to say you
mentioned I was going to quickly say
right you know if you have a platonic
friend and like mixed mixed like guy and
girl platonic friends you know
you see when sorry you see when if
you've got a male friend and your male
friend catches your boyfriend cheating
on you depending on how bad your choice
of man is because most women not most
I'm sorry some some women the judgment
is a bit questionable and then when it
goes left it's like oh my God how could
he do this to me yeah depending on the
type of character you've chosen to be
with do you know what position you've
put your brethren in when you're
breeding has to now think hold on this
could escalate people get shot over
these type of tunes trying to tell you
right you know your boyfriend the
gangster you chose to get with I gotta
tell you your gangster boyfriend he's
cheating on you when you invest that
can't lie I'm not telling him
I've had bad choice of friends you've
got bad choice of boyfriends I've been
there yeah yeah and when she asked me
when she asked me why didn't you tell me
I'll be like yep I I can't lie this is
on you no this is unique
I gave up speaking I gave up telling
women that their men are cheating on
them I gave up because the last thing
was like a few months ago it actually
happened to a to a platonic friend of
mine and I found out from another girl
that this girl's boyfriend was seeing
the both of them so I was like okay cool
I know this girl how cool do you know
what hey this is what's happened I've
got some information about your guide
he's seeing this other girl you know
what she done she mad at you oh no
is cheating on you and you want to know
about the girl yeah that's not wrong she
created she said okay let me speak to
her she spoke to her
and then the other girl got in contact I
knew both of them the other guy had gone
to contact with me oh she's a little bit
she created a WhatsApp group
you don't do what you're doing I ain't
got time
with women I'm the same like I'm not
talking I don't know that because I know
how women are yeah they're ready to just
be like who is she first of all yeah
yeah Touch Your Man why should another
woman have any loyalty sorry oh probably
going to stay there and just do so what
is the point right well that that
happened to me once in college I told a
girl that her boyfriend was like
cheating on her and then oh my God she
stays with him and then the whole friend
group's mad at me so all of so made it
awkward because we're on Camp we're on
we're on campus and like like she she
wasn't mad at me but all of his friends
were like oh she's a snitch she doesn't
stay out of people's business I'm like
you're just mad you got caught cheating
but that's the thing about it as I said
a lot of the time women and both men and
women know
that their partner's actually a cheater
yeah yeah
if we think we're going to tell them
information that they already know
but then does that mean that you a
question then about that does that mean
that you're gonna tell your friend to
look up how they conduct their
relationship because you don't think
that they're do you know what I mean
like you know when people yeah no I
understand you know some people like
well would you want your friend to have
their happiness are you supportive of
how they live is it something that's in
line with your values
I've got an RC so what you do is at the
start of the relationship or like when
it's festering you tell them look I
think this is a bad idea yes I don't
there's red flags like you probably
shouldn't go there yeah yeah now when
they make their bed let them lie in it I
agree with what you're saying because I
think a lot of the time we let off
people will let their friends go and be
with this person that person you may
have your views on it and if you love
your friend tell them if you care about
them in the same way that something you
were talking about earlier is something
unrelated if you think your friends are
not getting the man or woman of their
dreams maybe they should actually look
at why that is I've done that before
yeah I'm like okay well hun if you
actually look at how you've conducted
yourself previously it isn't surprising
to me that get on the track treadmill
that that person doesn't want to be with
you so you know if you're a true friend
you should be able to have that yeah
communication with your friends as
adults to just have a conversation if it
doesn't if they don't they don't have to
take it on that's to sit in the next
thing but at least you you you can have
your peace and just let them live quick
question to you so then Midway through
like the relationship so you've already
had that gone through that phase do you
feel like you should still be trying to
tell your friend that's now how the
situation happen to them it depends
situations for example when my friend
will continuously complain about the
same things with their partner drop me
out we've had this discussion I've given
you my advice and an honest opinion you
don't have to take it but if you're
going to keep going in the same vicious
cycle I honestly don't really want to
hear about the same thing that your man
or your partner's done and you don't
want to take on anyone's suggestions in
order to make you happy but you're going
to keep emotionally dumping things on me
for absolutely no reason you're draining
me at this point and I don't want to
hear about it anymore so I'll just
remove myself from hearing about your
man I've done that the people of some
women are actually addicted
some women really do love it and it's
the same thing with also and I hate to
say it domestic violence sometimes
because even as you pointed out in
domestic situations
um it takes two right sometimes the
women they know the triggers they know
what they're doing to get a man to that
point and then they like the fact that
the man has to grovel and beg back and
do all of this and whatever there's so
many different aspects so the same way
with cheating oh you know the type of
man you chose you know that potentially
he could he he's going to do that and
he's going to continue to do that but
because you like the fact that your
friends will rally around you or your
friends will be the ones that will call
you and be like oh my God I just saw him
in marks and Spencer's and he was with
Sarah and you know whatever whatever and
it's that attention seeking so and you
can tell and I've Got Friends certain
friends like that and you can tell when
they are just so like misery loves
company yes and I'm not a miserable
person so there's only so much of my
time I can give you and so much of my
energy that I can put into your toxic
situation I'm gonna give my two two
pence in and after that babes you're on
your own and I I agree with that for me
personally I've had friends where their
relationship was really toxic and I took
a break from being around them even
though I was friends with both of them I
was like I don't want to see this
anymore so I'll take a break until you
guys you don't have to stay with friends
you know if you don't agree with how
they live I think people condone certain
behavior and then they send out mixed
signals because one minute is oh your
man did this and then the next minute
when your homegirl cheats you're like
yeah he was a [ __ ] anyway why are
you saying toe it was fine but you were
casting out a man you need to stop being
so hypocritical and actually either live
in your values and your truth and and
expel that or you're just living a lie
basically so for me it comes down to
your more your your morals and if you're
actually gonna portray that okay I'm
gonna finish this super chats real quick
okay
um December zero eight one um women want
to be wanted men want to be needed
dragon
stallion1001 ladies choose one a man who
fulfills all of your sexual needs but is
a bum or a man who fulfills all of your
financial needs and and is a good
husband but sucks in bed
what can you repeat that okay okay what
would you pick so a man who fulfills he
best sex your life but he's a bum or a
great husband fulfills the financial
needs but bad and bad oh my gosh
now when I was younger I would have
chose the second option now that I'm in
my sexual maturity I need great sex
Vibes and everything else
[Laughter]
that's why I've done all of that I've
lived that life
and babes so like listen we all we all
need it and it's amazing and you know
what it does it gives you comfort you
step out in this world what a killing
time you'll see you can't make this [ __ ]
up have you ever seen a chicken
[Laughter]
he can still have a little bit of
everything else right but guess what
Batman has great sex and might be a
little bit of a bum I can motivate him
to be a better person
get that money no but this is this is
the problem with a woman you think you
can change a man no they are right if
he's gonna be your age he's been this
way for 40 30 40 years right he's not
changing he's a once a bum always a bomb
bombs don't just magically like bumps
bombs just don't magically get jobs as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible